الخطاب الذي نسمعه من
فلاديمير بوتين ينذر بالخطر لأنه
يتحدث كثيرًا عن الأسلحة النووية
ويبدو أنه من المرجح أكثر من أي وقت مضى أنه
قد يفكر في فعل ذلك ، لكنني أتساءل ما
مدى احتمالية ذلك برأيك ، هل
تعتقد أنه سيفعل ذلك حقًا  لا
نعرف ، أعتقد أنه من غير المحتمل ولكنه
ممكن ، وأعتقد أنه كلما
استمر الأوكرانيون في السيطرة على الأرض
في الشرق والجنوب ، أعتقد أنه
كلما أصبح بوتين يائسًا ، أعني أن
هذا كان فشلًا استراتيجيًا
بطرق متعددة منذ ذلك الحين  لقد بدأت في فبراير
، والآن أخيرًا يتحدث الشعب الروسي
عنك ، هناك احتجاجات مستمرة في
جميع أنحاء البلاد ،
وقد غادر مئات الآلاف من الروس روسيا
لتجنب هذا التجنيد ، وأعتقد أن بوتين
يواصل رسم نفسه في
الزاوية دون أي شيء ويحد من
خياراته  للخروج من هذه الفوضى التي
أحدثها ، ومن الواضح أننا نحاول أن
نفهم جيدًا كيف سيبدو ذلك
إذا فعل ذلك كنا نتحدث مع
خبير نووي جو سورنشي  بالأمس
الذي كتب هذه المقالة الرائعة في
واشنطن بوست حول
خيارات بوتين والأرجح بين
السيناريوهات الأربعة ستكون في
رأيه سلاحًا نوويًا منخفض
القوة يمكن استخدامه على هدف عسكري أوكراني
نتحدث عن شيء ما
في حدود 10 كيلو طن من مادة تي إن تي ،
كان ما يعادل
هيروشي شيما للإشارة فقط 15 كيلوطنًا ، لذلك هذا
كبير جدًا ، هل تعتقد أن هذا صحيح
هو أنك تعتقد أن شارعه الأكثر احتمالًا
، أعتقد أن أي مكان بين 1 إلى 10
كيلوطن تكتب هيروشيما كان  15
كيلوطن قتلت 70000 شخص دمرت
خمسة أميال مربعة من الأراضي
حول المدينة وأعتقد أن الطريقة التي يمكن أن
ينقلها بها على الأرجح في هذه الحالات هي من
خلال قنبلة الجاذبية التي يتم تسليمها بواسطة
طائرة أو نوع من صواريخ إسكندر كروز.
يتعين على
الإدارة أن تفعله هو جمع
الحلفاء معًا ، والآن نتحدث عن إعادة
باتش باك إلى موسكو ، لكن قل علنًا
انظر إذا رأينا نوعًا من
المؤشرات الاستراتيجية  عندما
تسحب الأسلحة النووية التكتيكية من مناطق التخزين ،
سنضع غطاءًا هوائيًا فوق
أوكرانيا وسنقوم بإسقاط
أي شيء يأتي باتجاه أوكرانيا والذي
قد يحمل سلاحًا نوويًا ،
فهناك أشياء مثل  يمكننا القيام به
لمنع ذلك من أجل تهدئة الأمر نوعًا ما
والحفاظ على احتواء بوتين